Hey youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Walking Dead Episode
2 video.
Probably the best episode of Walking Dead
I've ever seen.
I can't remember the last time off the top
of my head that the "B" team had such an exciting
story.
They did an amazing job.
Just remember that all the big hitters are
dealing with the super pack right now which
we actually didn't see during this episode
so this is going to get into it there's so
much that they bought and all explained that
new character is Denise Cloyd she's right
out of the comics just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet in new
round of the giveaway starts now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video here we go starting
with top five WTF moments number five meet
Denise Cloyd she's the new doctor same story
in the comics a gets is ripped right off the
page she explained she has medical training
she was going to be a surgeon but in the apocalypse
happened so she just trying to do the best
that she can in the adorable thing about her
show me her name is Mary Weaver in real life
that's the name of the actress is that she
is a coward just like Eugene they did seem
like they're tailor-made for each other like
both of them have a natural tendency towards
cowardice for the book very useful wants to
go to that fear hump like was the get over
the initial fear of whatever situation is
happening probably my favorite Denise moment
though was it was like the awkward introduction
it was at the end went when everyone was starting
to feel the grief of what had happened and
Terrace slowly walking away and says I just
actually just wanted to remind you get the
brain Denise is still experiencing the shock
of losing the patient on the table and the
craziness is going on in terror just like
slips that industry casually like don't don't
forget to get her brain when I'm expecting
from her character is that she'll survive
his long as they have the save zone so if
they end up destroying the save zone the season
then all bets are off it seems like shall
be on the show at least through episode eight
usual and The Walking Dead blows places up
like big locations into the premieres midseason
finale's for the regular season finale on
the number for the Jessie holds out and gives
the wool a giant haircut in the chest the
best thing about this isn't the tension like
the moment before the storm before everything
goes crazy it's when she's in the middle of
it in her eyes go all crazy and Ron walks
up really quietly behind her and just watches
his mom stab the ship out of this wolf he
is never going to cut his hair again Alexander
Breckenridge the actress is a series regular
I think so I'm expecting the Jessie is going
to be aroused they might have to change her
plot from the comics there in the middle of
no way out that's like that the comic that
they're working through right now on the TV
show so they could do her story from the comics
but it seems like they might in the change
you those of you that are read the comics
do you think that this encounter that Jessie
had her killing the wool is evidence that
they've completely changed her storyline from
the comics or do you think that that is still
coming down the road please use spoiler tag
just in case people don't want to know what
ends up happening the Jessie in the comics
reaction learn a little bit more about what's
going on with her character when she's talking
to Ron in the early parts the episode but
before the ship hit the fan mostly that she
still on pretty good terms with Rick even
though she acknowledges that these are kinda
weird it was kinda hard to tell where they
stood after that black-and-white flashback
and episode one like it she just like completely
just get a push them away or they can continue
to be close to it seems like Jessie and Rick
might still be a thing but usually that's
the kiss of death for characters on TV show
like once was you enter into a loving relationship
you turn the one of Beth's boyfriends you
get marked for death on the number three though
Enid's intro I would say this is on par with
Bob's intro from the second half of season
for the there was an episode they just have
this really long Bob introduction for you
saw what happened to him before he met the
survivors just like me an alcoholic walking
down the road to music the JSS turns out to
stand for just survive somehow it does kinda
sound like something that a teenager would
come up with just like a really simple phrase
I thought it would either be that are her
original name before the apocalypse said as
if he needed was a name that she gave herself
after the apocalypse started my favorite thing
about Enid wasn't those scenes with Carl let
me know that was kinda touching to see Carl
get those moments you don't see a lot of really
big Carl scenes but now that Chandler Riggs
is slowly getting older I think you're going
to see more more that the gonna start giving
him more scenes but it was when she found
the turtle and she just ate it like you would
eat a crab just cracking the shell open and
just taking the bits out totally gross but
it was so funny to see her right JSS with
the bones in the ground like the awkward kind
of funny where your laughing but you're also
a little bit scared that's one of the awesome
things about The Walking Dead like he can
make you laugh it like really awkward moments
that you later feel bad about like oh I shouldn't
be laughing about this someone is getting
their head chopped in half speed which on
my number two moment Jedi Morgan versus the
wolves so there was this really meta-thing
going on in the episode that that I'm going
to spread across by number two number one
moments where was kinda putting forth Carol's
ideology versus Morgan's ideology Morgan has
this really good speech was talking to the
wall for his like you can continue on this
way Ross you're going to die like violence
will only breed more violence you you live
by the sword you die by the sword for only
an episode to just expect that theme to continue
those competing ideologies another conversation
made it seem like Morgan had been a wolf previously
like that of the Wolf seem like he knew really
well like oh my God it's you you're that guy
is totally possible they could have known
each other for an extended period of time
what I thought that the Wolf was referring
to was the season five finale when we see
Morgan in the flashback and is traveling along
and runs into that will that he later was
not able to kill and that's another thing
to winning the debate in the comments do you
think that you are because of the way they
were positioning Carol and Morgan in this
episode that Morgan killed that wolf at the
end you can't do it but you should've done
it before so I think the implication is is
that he ran him off like that wolf is still
alive and he will continue to be a villain
for the next couple of episodes in season
five I think I said in my episode one video
but there's always two different kinds of
conflicts The Walking Dead this conflict inside
the group like these two competing ideologies
of Carol versus Morgan's philosophy and then
you have conflict outside the group with you
know with actual villains that are trying
to stab you in the face the wolves that survived
in this episode the ones that Morgan ran off
along with this guy might end up being bad
external conflict doing in addition to the
super pack which is totally still coming to
finally on my number one WTF moment Rambo
Carol blows her cover is a step for his wife
is much as Morgan had some amazing scenes
in this episode playing off of Carol this
is really Carol's episode and I know I said
this is kind like the B team like this is
like the B team episode because all the eight
players were out dealing with the super pack
but Carol is like an 18 member like one of
the hard hitters disguised as a B team member
some actually registered to see how the rest
of the save zone deals with Carol now that
they know that she's a confirm bad ass like
oh you know how to use all these weapons and
you know how to use camo and you're not afraid
to kill people on site or leave people to
die like egg like father Gabriel for instance
that was interesting just walk right past
is like he's fine she was totally ready to
let them die in the end of the episode which
is sitting on her porch with those cigarettes
the cigarette thing that's like a whole other
thing we had to talk about that was so funny
just the way people's conversations inform
successive seems like quick the cigarettes
tracing the path of the cigarettes I feel
like they left things ambiguous on purpose
like you know she's kinda crying over that
cigarette she saw the a the kinda reminded
her of train car a then she passed Morgan
on the street like they were walking down
each other's paths that's why thought that
Morgan might've killed the Wolf because he
walked down the path to Carol and walked down
but I think they just wanted you to feel like
Carol was considering what Morgan was saying
like if I continue down this path then I'm
going to die violence will meet with more
violence the real reason the you have to admire
Carol is that even more so than Rick she's
so much more ready than Rick to give up her
humanity to protect the people that she cares
about Rick kind of does that it is still takes
him a little while to get going in any given
situation he still pauses to give thought
Carol is just like is automatic the minute
she sees cigarette woman get the hatchet buried
in her face she immediately activates Rambo
mode and is I love the camo that she was using
to the other wolves thought that she was one
of their friends because she took the clothes
off of one of their bodies so if you want
to explain this episode to someone who doesn't
watch The Walking Dead just say there's a
whole bunch of characters they were doing
spring cleaning they were making spring cleaning
casseroles is like the show is shaking the
tree and getting some of the cast members
to fall down freshening things up even though
technically it's the fall using can't recall
spring cleaning let me know in the comments
though what was your favorite moment and where
do you think that Enid is going like do you
think that will see her again or she just
she gone forever and what do you think is
going to happen with the super pack next week
because they're still coming I mean I expect
event just walk up all like a with what's
going on we are there was a party just remember
that the walkers are relatively slow even
though there are billion of them so we see
Rick running down the streets of the probably
get back to the save zone to tell everyone
hey there is a ship ton of walkers headed
this way I will be really interested to see
how they top episode two though episode two
felt so great it was that much better because
it was the be characters like whenever Darrell's
on-screen whenever Rick's around you expect
bad as things to happen because they're bad
ass characters when you have people like Carl
you have like all the lesser characters you
know you just you don't expect quite as much
so when they deliver like this you just like
oh my God this is amazing so giant high-fives
best episode of season six so far hopefully
things get better I'll be really disappointed
if it all went downhill from here but what
can happen tomorrow is is because there's
a new Star Wars trailer that's gonna be my
video tomorrow so my walking deck Q&A will
post later in the week like it has the last
couple weeks I feel like if you have to bump
things it mighs well be for new Star Wars
footage so everybody freak out that video
will post till later in the night but if you
have ESPN they're going to aired on TV during
Monday Night Football on ESPN that is so white
as way for new Star Wars footage you can click
here for the last episode seven teaser that
I posted earlier today in here for all my
The Walking Dead videos thank you so much
watching everybody high five and I'll see
you guys tomorrow!